l'europe n'est pas une construction
institutionnelle et technocratique
froide c'est avant tout une civilisation
commune avec des valeurs et des
principes communs aujourd'hui elle est
attaquée
nous avons le devoir de défendre notre
civilisation en ur et armand on our et
armand pour défendre notre culture notre
identité et nos valeurs pour cela tout
étranger qui souhaite vivre en europe
devra signer une charte des valeurs et
des devoirs pour vivre en europe
il faut accepter notre mode de vie il
faut accepter l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes
accepter la mixité respecter la
supériorité des lois politique sur celle
de la religion il faut aussi que
l'europe défende les droits des femmes
que les robes défendre les droits des
femmes contre l'excision contre
l'obscurantisme contre l'islamisme
contre l'enfermement
nous avons un héritage dont nous devons
être fiers et nous devons inscrire dans
cette charte des valeurs et des devoirs
l'héritage gréco roma les racines judéo
chrétiennes de l'europe et l'héritage
des lumières